in the vast category of what we call
hinduism
there is a huge diversity when it comes
to everything from
practices to beliefs but in any case
among this incredible diversity of
different schools of thought
ideas and ritual tendencies there is
perhaps no
school of thought or philosophy more
famous
or admired really in the western world
than what is known as
advaita vedanta advaita which means
literally
not two is a non-dualistic
interpretation of the vedas and
especially the upanishads
and has become one of the most important
and influential
philosophical and religious intellectual
currents in the history of indian
thought
we talked about advaita briefly in my
previous video about
vedanta but in this video i want to dive
deeper
while a dwight de vedanta is a diverse
school in itself that can't really be
boiled down to a
single central figure per se and there
are arguments that it dates back
further in history still advaita vedanta
is
primarily associated with a certain
figure
by the name of shankara also sometimes
endearingly called
adi shankara or shankaracharya who is
also often considered to be its founder
so let's spend a few minutes talking
about this massively important figure
his understanding of advaita through his
interpretation
of the upanishads and through him also
the larger
school of advaitha vedanta generally
[Music]
shankara is an almost legendary figure
at this point
he is often considered the founder of
the school of advaitha vedanta however
some will argue that the non-dual or
advaita interpretation of the upanishads
existed since before his time
which we can see for example in the
writings of gaudapada
who were supposedly the teacher of
shankara's own teacher
this argument is convincing enough but i
still think that it isn't entirely
inaccurate to call him the founder of
advaitha vedanta on the basis that his
writings and teaching
has become so successful that he
functions as the
instigating figure of advaitha as we
know it today
with all of that said however trying to
reconstruct
a comprehensive biography of shankara is
almost impossible we have very little to
go by when it comes to contemporary
archaeological or trustworthy evidence
for his life
we do have traditional accounts of his
life written centuries after he died
which are often used in this context but
all of these accounts are so called
hagiographical
what this means that is hagiography is
that they are stories told from the
point of view
of revering the person in question
how geographies are the kind of life
stories we find told about great saints
or prophets of history
often characterized by miraculous and
incredible stories to showcase the great
power or stature of an individual
rather than being an accurate retelling
of historical events
aside from the hydrographical sources we
can also use the authentic writings of
shankara himself as well as records by
his students
to try and get an idea of who he was as
a historical person
all of these sources are problematic in
different ways
but it's basically all we have to go by
so when i do
tell biographical information in this
video you should always keep this in
mind and thus also take it with a grain
of salt
we have basically nothing to go by when
it comes to the life of shankara so his
biography is basically
entirely up for debate even such a basic
thing as
dating is contested some have suggested
that shankara lived between
788 to 820 a.d others think that he
lived centuries before
many scholars today will argue and i
think we can be safe in assuming
that shankara probably lived sometime
around the year
700 a.d he was from a brahmana
family that is the highest priestly
caste in the
varna system of social structure in
india the
famous caste system many accounts
state that he was from the kerala region
in south west
india and that at a very young age he
would leave his home and family to
become a
sanyasin a wandering ascetic
as a brahmana he would have studied the
veda scriptures and was later taught
vedanta in particular under a teacher by
the name of govinda
it is this teacher that in turn is said
to have been taught by the famous
proto-advaitan
gowdapada nonetheless shankara clearly
became somewhat of a master or teacher
himself
as he started to wander all around india
gathering
students and disciples of his own as he
debated with philosophers from various
schools of thought around the
subcontinent
apparently defeating all of them with
his very impressive rhetorical skills
we can't hear any of these debates today
of course but a lot of that skillful
rhetoric can certainly be found in the
writings that are attributed to shankara
he seems to have written quite a lot and
judging from the texts that have
survived
he was a master of sanskrit
argumentation and style
there is some disagreement on which of
the writings attributed to shankara
should be considered authentic
but generally scholars tend to agree
that we can be safe in assuming
that at least the great commentaries
that he wrote
are should be attributed to shankara
himself
this includes a great commentary also
known as abashia
on the brahma sutras as well as a
commentary on the bhagavad-gita
and several of the most important
upanishads
there are also many other texts
attributed to shankara
including prose works as well as for
example hymns to
different gods but they are more
controversial when it comes to
authenticity
but still based on those writings that
are considered authentic by most
scholars that i mentioned
we can use them to still reconstruct a
pretty good idea
about the personality and ideas of this
great hindu
sage more than this is hard to say when
it comes to the life
of shankara a life that was very
eventful but
short because indeed another one of the
most recurring themes in the different
biographical material
is that shankara died at a very young
age
at the age of 32 and certainly he seems
to have accomplished
quite a lot in that short amount of time
shankara can be a very hard person to
pin down
we should remember that what we call
hinduism today
hadn't really developed into the form
that we know it as
today back in shankara's lifetime
and so it can be very hard to place
within a specific pocket in that sense
some have speculated that shankara was a
shaivite that is
shaivism is the tradition of hinduism
where shiva is worshipped as the primary
deity
but other aspects of his writings
suggest a familiarity and and
a great understanding of the vaisnava
tradition as well that is the
tradition of worshiping vishnu as the
primary deity but again none of these
traditions were fully developed at this
time
it was still pretty young and so in my
opinion it's pretty anachronistic to try
and place shankara within one of these
specific categories
also i think we shouldn't get too bogged
down in details like that
now it's a very modern obsession i'll be
i think a very worthwhile one
to be so focused on the historical
person in question
rather than focusing on what arguably is
more important which is of course what
he taught
what he came to represent and symbolize
for later developments both in
advaithas particularly but also in
hinduism more generally
the context in which he lived and worked
is of course
very important for getting a
comprehensive view of where his
ideas figure into the wider picture and
in that sense the question of shaivism
versus vaishnavism
is actually pretty significant not so
much in the sense of what tradition
shankara himself belonged to if any
but rather to point out that devotional
worship
known as bhakti was becoming a
significant movement
at the time of shankara's life bhakti
is the devotional worship of a deity
through rituals like
puja aspects which we very strongly
associate with hinduism today
bhakti this particular form of religious
practice and belief
would eventually eclipse the earlier
vedic rituals almost entirely but
during shankara's life this was still a
pretty new movement
only one among a multitude of schools of
thought philosophies and traditions
that make up the historical and
intellectual context
of shankara's environment in fact the
intellectual
environment in which shankara writes and
teaches
is a very diverse one filled with
various schools and thinkers competing
as well as influencing each other
sometimes we talk about what is known as
the six orthodox schools of
hindu philosophy and while this
simplified things to a degree
the movements included on that list were
very significant during shankara's time
all of them debating which of the
various means of gaining knowledge known
as pramana
was the most legitimate the schools of
nyaya
and vaishesika placed an emphasis on
reason
and logic arguing that brahman and truth
could be reached by
reason alone others like the purva memsa
school considered scripture
that is the vedas to be the primary or
only way of reaching true knowledge and
emphasize the importance
of the vedic rituals aside from these
so-called
orthodox schools of philosophy usually
only those schools that are connected to
the vedas as scriptures and
what we call hinduism today there are
also other significant movements like
buddhism and jainism that were
flourishing at the time too
the former of which had a particularly
strong standing in society
and probably influenced shankara a lot
shankara as we have seen spent much of
his life
traveling around the indian subcontinent
meeting with various representatives of
these various
schools of thought he would meet with
buddhists with
jains with the representatives of the
nyaya and vaishyazuka schools and so on
and he would debate them and argue with
them over who had the
right means to true knowledge
even in the writings of shankara this
form of argumentation is
present as well this was the main form
of writing prose
or treatises at the time and shankara
also uses this technique of trying to
first
present the opinions of his opponents
so he will say this is what the buddhist
says this is the objection of the nyaya
scholars this is the
and so on and so on and at the final
section
he will present the vedantin which is
his own position
and which he of course considers to be
the right one in terms of doctrinal
alignment or philosophical alignment
shankara
took influence and pointers from many of
these different philosophical schools
but from one perspective we could say
that shankara was particularly close to
the school known as
purva mimsa especially in the sense that
he emphasized
that scripture was the only valid means
of knowledge when it comes to knowing
the brahman
but what was this truth that was to be
reached
in other words what is the philosophy of
shankara
the school of thought that is associated
with shankara and which is sometimes
considered to have been
founded by him is referred to as advaita
vedanta
or non-dual vedanta advaita
literally translates to not two and the
reason why will become pretty clear
soon advaita vedanta is characterized by
the idea that
the absolute reality known as brahman
is the only thing that truly exists
in the words of eliot dutch quote
brahman
the one is a state of being it is not a
he a personal being nor is it an
it's an impersonal object brahman
is that state which is when all subject
object distinctions are obliterated
brahman is ultimately a name for the
experience of the timeless plenitude of
being
brahman is a concept that is recurring
in the vedic scriptures
especially in the upanishads but
descriptions or references to it often
presents very different and sometimes
even contradictory statements
which has lent itself to many different
interpretations
but to shankara and advaita vedanta all
is the brahmana there is nothing which
is not
the brahmana the one brahman is the very
reality of the world that we experience
an unfathomable oneness in which
multiplicity
is ultimately an illusion this is often
expressed by shankara and many others
through the vedic quote tatvam asi
you are that or thou art that
this phrase has also been interpreted in
various ways but to shankara and his
followers it is read quite literally
you meaning the person or self with
which you identify
are that meaning the brahman literally
you are the brahmana everything is the
brahmana
quote brahman is real the world is
illusory
the self is not different from brahman
shankara's stance seems to be pretty
straightforward it is a very staunch
monism but let's unpack the nuances and
complexities of what all of this
actually means
shankara begins his brahma sutra basia
that is his commentary on the brahma
sutras
with an assumption that is the starting
point for understanding him
and advaita vedanta generally that is
that the self that we identify with and
the way that we look on the world the
way we conceive of the world around us
is ultimately based on a false
assumption or a misunderstanding
when we say the word i like in i am
hungry or
i am sad we are confusing the mind and
the body
with the actual self it is my body that
is hungry
not the eye to which i am referring
similarly it is the mind that is
sad or feels emotions not the actual
self
that which we are actually referring to
when we use the word
i the actual self stands beyond these
things
it experiences them but as things other
than itself or as beings thinks outside
of itself
all of us think that we are these
various things i am
a human being i am the son of so-and-so
i am swedish but all of this is
ultimately based on a misunderstanding
it's all
false and similarly when we look on the
world around us we
also conceal a bunch of different things
separate
objects like it's a tree outside
that's a rock this is a chair but again
this
is all false the true self which we are
actually referring to when we use the
word i
is none of these things it's not the
body
it's not the mind it's none of these
conceptual
things these individual components that
we
apply to it the actual
true self which is known as the atman
is according to shankara in fact
completely identical
to the brahman the absolute reality
similarly again if we look at the world
around us
the tree is not a tree the rock is in
fact not a rock and this chair is
not a chair it's all just brahman so our
view of ourselves and the world around
us is fundamentally skewed
this is the reason we are doomed to be
reincarnated and are trapped in the
wheel of samsara
this basic human condition or the reason
for it
is called avidia meaning ignorance
however ignorance doesn't really capture
what shankara is trying to say with the
word
it isn't really a passive lack of
knowledge that is at play
but an active misunderstanding
another word used by shankara which
perhaps functions a little better to
explain it
is aviyasa meaning superimposition
we are superimposing things onto the one
brahman
actively misidentifying ourselves and
the world
as something else or as something
independent when it is all just brahman
ultimately quote owing to an absence of
discrimination
there continues a natural human behavior
in the form of i am this or
this is mine this is avidya
it is a superimposition of the
attributes of one thing on another
the ascertainment of the nature of the
real entity by separating the
superimposed things from it
is vidya knowledge or illumination
one allegory that shankara loves to use
to explain this idea
is the famous example of the snake and
the rope
suppose you're walking along some road
and suddenly you see a snake lying
before you
naturally you get scared and concerned
over the danger that it may pose
but you then carefully look a little
closer and you realize that what you
thought was a snake
was in fact only a rope you had
identified the rope as being a snake
which also caused you distress
this is how avidya and alvasa work
we think that what we see is the snake
but it is really only the rope
in this case it is really only the
brahman and this is an important detail
to keep
in mind often when we talk about advaita
or
shankara we place a huge emphasis on
this word
maya which is then translated as
illusion
and that the world is seen as this grand
illusion but
this can very easily be misunderstood
shankara doesn't actually use the word
maya as much as we often like to think
and when he does use the word it is
basically used interchangeably
with the word avidya and while it is
somewhat legitimate to translate it as
illusion it
doesn't really mean illusion in the
regular sense of how we understand that
word
shankara was actually a realist he
didn't deny
that the world was ontologically real or
claim that it was some
phantom or a simulation to use a modern
example
what is illusory about the world is the
superimposed concepts that we apply to
it when we
conceive of it as being something other
than the brahman
just like in the snake and rope example
when one realizes that the snake was in
fact a rope
the rope doesn't just disappear into
nothingness we are just giving a new
perspective
on the actual reality of the rope it
wasn't a snake
that was the illusion but it's still
something it's still a rope
quote there could be no non-existence of
external entities
because external entities are actually
perceived
an external entity is invariably
perceived in every cognition such as a
pillar
wall a pot a piece of cloth it can never
be
that what is actually perceived is
non-existent
and again returning to the snake and
rope example quote
when it is determined that it is nothing
but the rope alone
then all illusions regarding the rope
disappear
and the non-dual knowledge that there
exists nothing else
but the rope becomes firmly established
shankara isn't presenting a existential
nihilism
something that he actually accuses the
buddhists of doing perhaps
inaccurately so but what he is saying is
that the illusion
is when we can see of anything in our
experience as being anything other
than the brahman and since brahman is
very much
real in an ultimate sense this means
that the world we experience
is also real as long as it is understood
as being simply the brahman and nothing
else in other words it is the constructs
that we create about the world
that is the illusion but the brahman is
the reality of the world
and since the brahman is real in that
sense and
and so far as it is the brahman the
world is absolutely real
the goal of life to shankara like for so
many hindus
is to reach liberation or moksha from
the cycle of rebirths
and according to him this can only be
achieved by reversing the
misidentification of things
and to realize knowledge of brahman
here he differs from many other schools
of thought within hinduism at the time
especially the purvamsa school by
denying the central role of rituals and
practices
for reaching liberation now he doesn't
necessarily deny
the usefulness of rituals but he is
claiming that their rewards are only
temporary
instead liberation is only reached
through
knowledge known as jnana to know
the brahmana is to be liberated but
knowing the brahmana
is not like knowing any object in the
world
in this sense the brahman can't be known
in fact
knowledge of brahman is not knowledge of
brahman as an
object for brahman is different from the
known and above the unknown
rather it is being brahman knowing
brahman not as an
object but as being identical with one's
true self
that is self-reflexive consciousness
beyond subject
object duality this is liberation
our true state from which all
superimpositions have finally been
removed
if knowledge has a function it is to
remove these superimpositions
not to produce some new result it is
from the notion of this basic human
condition of
ignorance misunderstanding and
superimposition
and with the goal of being liberated
through knowledge of oneself as being
the same as the brahman that shankara
and advaita then presents
its further ideas and positions quotes
and the realization of brahman is the
highest human objective
for it completely eradicates all such
evils as ignorance etc
that constitute the seed of
transmigration
therefore brahman should be deliberated
on but how is this salvific knowledge
reached according to shankara well the
answer here is pretty simple
it is reached through scripture to
shankara the only pramana or
source of knowledge when it comes to the
brahman is scripture
namely the vedas in contrast to many
other schools of thought he denies the
legitimacy of things like
sense perception or even reason as ways
of reaching true knowledge
now that isn't to say that he denies
these things completely
sense perception and reason are useful
tools for understanding the conventional
world of multiplicity
but when it comes to reaching knowledge
of the brahman
scripture is the only way to do it and
correct interpretation of scripture at
that
quote the realization of brahman results
from the firm conviction
arising from the deliberation of the
vedic texts and their meanings
but not from other means of knowledge
like inference etc
in order for scripture to be interpreted
correctly according to shankara
he also here of course places a huge
emphasis on the importance of having a
vedantan teacher to relay these this
knowledge
to the student and here he also allows
for a certain
reason in terms of religious matters in
other words
through correct interpretation of the
vedic scriptures by an accomplished
non-dualist teacher
the seeker can realize knowledge of
one's true self as being none other than
the one brahman
and thus reached liberation through this
state of non-dual consciousness
this very heavy scripturalism of
shankara is one thing that might be
pretty surprising to a lot of people
today
another area in which this comes to the
surface is in shankara's requirements
for who is even allowed to enter into
the study of advaita or the brahman
while there is some disagreement among
scholars on this in many of his writings
including the treatise a thousand
teachings
shankara seems to think that only
individuals belonging to the highest
brahman caste are eligible as pupils
shankar of course lived in a context
where the caste system was a fact of
life and
this played a role in how he conceived
of his teachings and who
it was aimed at at the very least
shankara requires the people to have
studied the vedas
deeply which immediately disqualifies
the lowest
shudra caste as well as for example
women in a general sense
again there are different
interpretations of this and shankara's
writings
do sometimes allow for various readings
but it seems
clear that he took it for granted that a
student of advaitha
was a male of the brahmana caste
the important subject of shankara's firm
grounding in his religious
and intellectual environment carries
over to
other aspects of his teachings as well
as i mentioned in the beginning the
bhakti movement of devotional worship to
a personal deity
was becoming very popular in shankara's
day
and indeed one of the main sources of
vedanta and a text on which
shankana has commented is the
bhagavad-gita
a bhakti text centered on the god
krishna which again
also is an avatar of vishnu and
shankara's relationship with devotion or
bhakti and religious worship
generally is a very complex question on
which a lot has been written and
speculated
later critics of shankara such as
ramanuja and mavacharya
viewed shankara's advaita vedanta as
essentially denying the importance or
legitimacy of ritual worship
by of course claiming the absolute
identity between the individual self and
the brahman
but the situation also appears to be a
lot more complicated than that
indeed shankara frequently employs
devotional and
theistic language in his writings
talking about
ishvara or the lord often translated
also as
god as for example being the creator of
the universe and worthy of praise and
worship
much interpretation has gone into
understanding how this fits with his
general ideas of non-duality
many will say that shankara's talk about
the lord is only a kind of preliminary
language
bound to the world of superimposition
which only conceal or obscure his true
doctrines of advaita or
non-duality in this interpretation
ishvara or the lord who is often
identified as
visnu becomes a kind of second god who
is bound to the world of illusions
but that is ultimately as unreal as
anything else in the conventional world
but in many of shankara's writings this
position doesn't really
seem to hold he appears to use terms
like
brahman ishvara supreme self etc
interchangeably revealing a more complex
picture of the role of the lord and its
relationship to brahman and to the world
of misidentification
sometimes when talking about the
doctrines of advaita vedanta
and shankara there is talk about two
forms of or you can say two ways of
talking about brahman
on the one hand there is nirguna brahman
that is brahman without
attributes this is the absolute form of
brahman that is beyond all conceptions
and on the other hand there is saguna
brahman brahman with
attributes often also identified with
ishvara or
the lord or god the relationship between
these two can be obscure and there is
disagreement on this question as well
the important question here becomes that
the scholar eric lott puts it
quote are they two distinct brahmanas or
merely two
aspects of one brahman of course no one
would argue that shankara conceives of
two
actual brahmanas as that would
completely contradict the very basics of
his system
the question rather is is saguna brahman
or the lord
a different epistemological concept
bound by the world of multiplicity and
disappearing along with it
or are they in fact referring directly
to the same thing without distinction
as mentioned a lot of the writings of
shankara seems to
suggest or imply that the lord is in
fact completely identical to
the brahman but shankara also sometimes
seems to be defending
the practice of worshipping or of
devotion
to the lord or to god against
its critics or its enemies which seems
to go against the idea that shankara
only viewed
worship as preliminary or as unimportant
which a lot of his critics later
would accuse him of in the tradition of
advaita vedanta especially today
the idea of ishvara or god or visnu or
any of the gods
is often implemented as simply being a
certain expression of the brahman
as being the same as brahman but
representing different relationships
that we can have
with this ineffable source while this
has been a standard position among
adwaitans
that doesn't necessarily mean that it is
the position that shankara himself
proposes
but i think the wisest thing for me to
do here is to leave
this discussion to people who are a lot
more qualified to
talk about it there is disagreement
among scholars on how the idea of the
lord
should be understood or read in the
teachings of shankara
and i'm not going to attempt to to solve
that problem here
there are a lot more smart people people
who are smarter than me who can answer
this question a lot
better but a good takeaway here is that
all of this talk about the lord
either as cause or as an object of
worship containing different attributes
all of this is often provisional for
there to be a lord
there must be something to be ruled over
and since the world as such is only the
result
of misidentification this means that
when there is no world
there is no lord as such either at the
end of the day
all of this talk only functions within a
discussion about the world of name and
form
the world of superimposition and
illusion shankara's main points and the
whole purpose of advaitha
is the affirmation of the non-dual
nature of reality
that there is only the brahman and all
else is false attribution
so whatever is said about god or worship
or rituals as valuable as they may be
at the end of the day it is all relative
and only bound to the conventional world
the goal after all is to go beyond this
and realize one's own
total identity with the brahmana that
everything is
in a sense a single oneness this point
is what is
always affirmed by shankara just in many
different ways
another example that he likes to use to
explain this kind of situation
is another famous parable of the clay
pot the clay pot example is taken from
the upanishads where we find the quote
by knowing a lump of clay all things
made of clay are known what does this
mean
well think of various things made of
clay
including a pot maybe a sculpture or
just a simple lump of clay we may think
that
all of these things exist the pot the
sculpture and so on
but when we look closer they are all
simply made of one thing
that is clay so when we are looking at
the pot
what we are actually looking at is clay
when we are looking at the sculpture
what we are looking at
ultimately is clay it is only our minds
that conceptualize this clay into
various
things i see clay in one shape and i
call it a pot
i see it in another and it is a
sculptured statue
but these are only mental constructions
that are all just referring to one
single
thing that is again clay
so this is what the brahman is like
again
in philosophical language what truncate
is saying here is that the effect
pre-exists in the cause something
cannot come from nothing thus the
brahman as
cause is really what the world as effect
consists of
this philosophical position of the
effect pre-existing in its cause
which shankara held in opposition to
other schools at the time
is known as satkarigavada quote
our ordinary experience tells us that
milk
clay and gold are taken by people in
order to produce out of them
curds jars and ornaments respectively
no one who wants curds will expect to
have it out of clay
nor will anyone expect to have jars out
of milk
this means that the effect exists in the
cause
prior to its production for had the
effect been really non-existent before
its production
there is no reason why curds could not
be produced out of milk alone
or jars out of clay besides all the
effects being equally non-existent
anything might come
out of anything else but if we
understand the brahmanan world
relationship
only through this allegory of the clay
pot
we may get the false impression that the
brahmana actually changes
since the clay when it is formed into
these different things
it does change it takes different shapes
but the brahman does not function like
this the brahman is completely
unchanging and static this is why we
need that other example that i mentioned
also
the snake and rope example remember
the snake was only misidentified as
being a snake
it was only really the rope the rope
didn't
ever change into the snake it was only
the result of a
misidentification of the reality
of the rope which was due to avidia or
ignorance
after all from one perspective the
conventional world
is absolutely not brahman the world
consists of
various attributes concepts and
things and multiplicity and none of this
applies to the brahman which is
one without attributes and completely
unchanging
this is what shankara is talking about
when he uses another one of his favorite
phrases
which is neti neti or not this
not this as expressed in the upanishads
for example quote
there is no other or better description
of brahman than this
that it is not this not this that is
whatever we may think see or talk about
it is always based on distinction
definition and multiplicity
in other words the world of
superimposition and brahman
can be none of this but from an absolute
perspective
it is of course all the brahman yet only
if understood that brahman is the true
reality
of whatever is conceived not that the
particular features of our mental
constructs ever correspond
to the nature of brahman as such when we
think of the conventional world
we always see a bunch of things or
concepts
which means multiplicity inevitably but
as we have seen anything
that we conceive is really only a mental
construct
a superimposition based on ignorance
avidia
the same is true for ourselves when i
think of myself i think of a bunch of
different things
as i said in the beginning of this
discussion i may consider myself to be a
human being or as having a
body or experiencing various thoughts or
feelings
but to advise the vedanta the further we
investigate who this actual self this i
really is we start to penetrate into the
inevitable conclusion
that just like all things in the world i
am really nothing
i am just a silence that simultaneously
is
all things this is the atman
the true self atman which i've already
mentioned before
is one of the most central concepts in
all of vedanta
including for shankara of course
when talking about the individual cell
for the soul
the term jiva or jivatman is often used
but even this concept based as it is on
individuality and therefore difference
is ultimately not true in the ultimate
sense
quote the individual soul is not
directly the highest atma
because it is seen to be different on
account of the upadhis
nor is it different from the atma
because it is the atma who has
entered the jivatman in all the bodies
we may call the jiva as a mere
reflection of
the atman our true selves our
true reality is realized when we break
beyond the subject object duality
and into the pure consciousness that is
the atman
the self the real self quote
the self is not absolutely beyond
apprehension
because it is apprehended as the content
of the concept
i and because the self opposed to the
non-self
is well known in the world as an
immediately or self-revealing entity
the atman or self is not a thing
it's not an object that can be
experienced or
grasped in any way the atman is pure
subjectivity it's pure awareness and
consciousness it's not something that we
are aware of
it is the very act of being aware
and not just individually either it is a
kind of universal
self the atman is not just my
consciousness or your consciousness
but consciousness itself which we all
share in the ultimate oneness of
existence
to the adwaitan thinkers this is the
most self-evident reality
that is immediately proven by its own
qualities
quote the knowledge of the atman is
self-revealed and
is not dependent upon perception and
other means of knowledge
in other words it is clear to all of us
that we are aware right now
since you are currently listening to me
speak and
in an argument that very much reminds us
of what descartes would famously say a
couple of centuries later
the sage vidyaranya stated quote no one
can doubt the fact of his own existence
where want to do so who could the
doubter be
this is the atman our true self which is
the pure state of consciousness and
awareness
it is one timeless spaceless and most
importantly to advise the vedanta in
particular
it is not different from the brahman
indeed this is after all the main point
of advaitha vedanta
the atman is identical to the brahman to
the absolute reality
the actual true self
is identical to absolute reality
thus we have come full circle we started
from the standpoint of avidia
maya and aviyasa ignorance and illusion
based on superimposition and
misidentification
and we have returned back from that to
the essential conclusions of the entire
system
the absolute oneness of all reality and
its essential identity
with brahman shankara's position on
reality and his interpretations of the
vedas
stands pretty clear it's right there in
the name advaita
not to to shankara there is no
multiplicity
there is only one there is only oneness
quote when duality is perceived to be
illusory
and atman alone is known as the sole
reality
then it is clearly established that all
our experiences
ordinary or religious verily pertain to
the domain of ignorance
then one perceives that there is no
dissolution i.e destruction
that which is non-dual advaitha can
never be said to be born
or destroyed that it should be non-dual
and at the same time
subject to birth and death is a
contradiction
in terms at my very core at your core at
the core of everything
is nothing but the one absolute reality
there is no difference between any of us
this is non-duality in its most clear
and
strict form shankara is of course a very
profound
thinker and his teachings have had a
vast impact on the intellectual climate
of india and really on the rest of the
world
in a direct sense it is said that he
opens several mafas or
monasteries and religious centers where
his lineage has survived to this day
he also taught students directly who
carried his legacy forward
but even aside from this his ideas have
spread across the world
and has indeed become one of the most
significant and influential schools of
thought
in all of what we call hinduism there
would appear
many critics of shankara in later
periods even within the school of
vedanta itself
for example the thinker ramanuja
was very critical of some of shankara's
monistic ideas and instead
favored a kind of compromise in his own
system which is known as
vishishtadvaita or qualified non-dualism
something that we will dedicate a future
video to and while western scholars of
the last few centuries
have often over emphasized the
importance of
shankara and advaita vedanta in hinduism
largely
for example was
adapted to a much larger degree by the
vaishnavites historically
there's still no denying that advaita
and shankara
stands as one of the pillars of this
vast tradition of
vedanta but also of hinduism in a much
more general sense
shankara is a very popular figure today
both
in his native india but also in the
western world and around
the world globally as i've mentioned his
the way that he's presented today is
often removed from a lot of his
historical religious and intellectual
environment
and context but still the core ideas
that he presents of non-duality
is one that is very popular and
influential to many
modern religious movements as well
again very impressive for someone who
supposedly only lived for
32 years i'll see you next time
as always this video is brought to you
by our patrons
the new ones include barry nobles and
faris al rosabi
thank you both so much and of course a
special shout out to all of my patrons
in the
saint category adam shraeby faris
badawi hanan fikri just the truth
muhammad mudasir richie able
sandy jabber stuart cleland sayeth
hashemi
sayed jafari while muhammad wasif khan
and amu latif thank you all so
so much if anyone else is interested in
becoming a patron and supporting my
free scholarly youtube videos that will
be immensely appreciated
you can of course become a monthly
patron supporter or just leave a
one-time donation
and i will leave all of the links to
that stuff in
the comments section and in the
[Music]
description
you